the material of kefir might be pretty
difficult because it's supposed to be
for very experienced tournament players
but I hope you guys will still enjoy it
the first position I'll show you is
illustrate an example of how to how to
try to win a ponding if you know the
basics of what you need to do here white
has two against one and of course the
pawns are blocked the question is can
white somehow create a passed pawn that
he's gonna nurse all the way to queening
and it's not so easy because if he goes
it seems like right now black has the
opposition black is opposing the white
king and how to break through it's like
in theory it seems like if white doors
here black might go here like it looks
like it looks like they can just dance
but you will notice that it's not so
simple at all the correct move is king
to e5 even though it looks in my opinion
looks a little paradoxical why are you
going away from your pawns well the idea
is to try to get the position where you
have the same opposition but but black
is on the move in other words that you
gain the opposition right now it's white
on the move so I will show you how it's
done first we have to avoid temptation
the first time thing thing is to play c6
Jack that looks really like a great move
here because one would think if pawn
takes king c5 looks like an awesome move
and now if black goes let's say King c8
we take the pawn if the King goes here
we pushed upon to b7 you have to come
out and I come in and I'm quitting very
very easily so alternatively in this
position after c6 jack
you go Kezia but wait let's analyze this
one first pawn takes King c5 if you go
King to DA that's a very mysterious move
the idea now after King takes c6 that'll
be a mistake because black immediately
gets the opposition and now after b7
check King b8 the only way to protect
the pawn is here and we have a stalemate
so I draw however I should only should
say this here here white will play king
d6 and now black is in a bind because if
he goes right the pond just Queens if he
goes left then again I get your position
and the point of getting the opposition
is when the King goes here and I push
the pawn you must go out and then the
King supports his pawn next move I queen
so now we understand this is what white
idea could be but black could be much
smarter that after c6 check he's gonna
play king c8 he does not take the pawn
he basically does this and now we have a
beautiful situation what can happen
of course if pawn takes pawn that's
nothing I just do this the key will
protect the pawn I'm gonna wait for the
king with your position when the King
shows itself again eventually we will
have a stalemate so then you might say
wait a leave why don't you just push the
pawn the problem here that you cannot
get the King out of the box you're just
gonna go
he basically gonna play King C 1887 you
cannot stop it because the moment you
try to stop it
stalemate the key will have no moves at
all so and there's no way for Y to stop
this tense of King C 1887 so that would
be a draw in this position of course we
have a draw also you will notice that
after King c8 if you play King d6 okay
we know now if pawn takes on c6 that's
gonna be a problem so you move the King
because pawn takes c6 King takes c6
White has the opposition and again white
is in the same problem that he has the
same issue that he had before if he
pushes the pawn I just drove
and either stalemate or perpetual dance
with the king if you play pawn takes and
I take that doesn't win anymore and of
course after King D 7
now I take and we know that when you
take back King c8 opposition and draw b7
t b8 King b6 stomach so very very
tempting continuation to play c6 check
but it doesn't work now watch what
happened when white gives black when
white manages to lose a tempo basically
he does king e5 and black has several
moves but he can no longer keep the
opposition if he tries to be opposing
then c6 and the pawn just marches in
whether you take it or let me take you
you know I take on b7 or if you take at
push b7 you cannot stop the pond
therefore you know you must play king c6
and now white goes back to defend this
pawn door where you can afford to lose
the pawn obviously and now black is
gonna go King be 7 if he tries to go out
that doesn't help either because I'm
just gonna go here and of course I'm
winning easily I'm just gonna go Queen
d7 King King b16 c7 and I'm going to
take this pawn and Queen this pawn it's
easy so he must play King t7 and now
King V 5 what happened we have the exact
same position we had in the beginning
but rather than be wide to move and he
went ke v now it's black dimmer and
whatever black goes he loses of course
if he goes away from the pawn like to
the e-file I'm just gonna play C 6 and
Queen my pawn without the effort so he's
gonna try to run with his King and now
King e6 diagonal opposition notice that
there's a position but in diagonal again
notice that white is very smart not to
play King d6 because if he goes King
these six black is gonna play King d8
that is not helping one bit
so King e6 and now black has two choices
here or b8 is the same you'll see
because here white plays King V 6 again
he's opposing king c8 again he is not
falling into the trap of playing c6
because black is just gonna go king b8
very very smart and again we know
pushing the pawn the king is gonna be
dancing forever if you take it's nothing
and therefore white plays King II 7 you
just edges the King to the corner Black
has one move and white keeps pushing and
now the poor King is in the corner now
that the king is stuck in the corner now
we can play the move c6 and now this
move wins now why does it win if you
take the pawn then of course I'm just
gonna play King c7 my pawn is ready to
Queen you can push this pawn let's say
and then check check and make very easy
I just Queen and win so alternatively
you might say well Aviv instead of
taking what if you just bring your King
back here well now the problem is that
after c7 and mate it's amazing how much
life there isn't an ending with only
three pawns two for white and one for
black again a position that looks so
innocent and it has like a world of
ideas but if you understand a position
like this if you understand what I
explained to you then you're already
doing very well you have to understand
when is it a win when is it a draw
it's very easy to make a mistake in an
ending like this any question about this
ending okay then we go to the next
position the next position is again it's
a beautiful example of how to win a
position how to solve the problem in the
position let me put it this way right
now it looks like white is just losing
completely losing well he can make a
queen first he is down a bishop and you
can already see that if you play let's
say a queen
I'm gonna go Bishop to f5 check a
beautiful skewer of the king and the
Queen when you move your King anywhere
I'm just gonna take your Queen
notice that the bishop ironically is
defending his pawn if you take that
bishop then I'm just gonna March my pawn
make a new queen of course this is
winning simply and any other move if you
don't take the bishop let's say you play
whatever I don't know if you play here
I'm
is gonna get my king closer and closer
and closer until eventually I'm just
gonna help push the pawn with the bishop
and make a new queen so what is boy to
do them can you even save the game and
the answer is yes the trick is to try to
use your King to do two things at the
same time and the win is really
beautiful it's really something that
well it's whatever it you're really
going to enjoy the first move is the
most ridiculous move on the probably the
last move you want to think about King
to c8 incredible what what kind of a
move is that you ask yourself not only
are you blocking your own porn from
cleaning but you're encouraging the
opponent pawn to just move forward and
and win the game but now so black of
course is playing b5 the most logical
move that there is and now why does a
switch back King to d7 a beautiful
return now he is threatening to Queen
the pawn why because that's pretend did
you place a move let's just pretend I
make a queen you will play a check to
win the Queen or else I'm gonna go here
and by the time you take the Queen I'm
gonna take your last born when a draw is
evident so in this position after I go
King b7 black needs to push his pawn
b4 further now again it looks really
gloomy for white he cannot stop the pawn
right I mean not even with the chopper
the point is so far advanced you can
stop it and if you Queen I always have
checked and I'm gonna win your Queen and
I have for pawn to to Queen my own Queen
but white plays King to d6 a brilliancy
well mom threatening to Queen my pawn so
if you push upon a like Queen well black
will lose so he must play Bishop to f5
and white plays King e5 attacking the
bishop now if the pawn advances we take
the bishop if the pawn advances we Queen
that's going to be a draw each side is
going to Queen and that's going to be
Queen versus Queen and a draw because in
an open position Queen versus queen is
not winning
yeah well I'm about to get into inside
the square exactly if you try to move
your bishop and save save the queen
then of course the King goes somehow and
mysteriously the king that summer in
Honolulu is all of a sudden right next
to the pawn and the pawn is not cleaning
anymore there's no way for black to save
his pawn anymore
so again from from the top again I think
it's one of the most brilliant endings
that I've ever seen I've seen it many
years ago I remember as a relative
beginner I was just in awe it was just
impressive to see how to do it again
queening doesn't work any key move just
doesn't work because black is gonna play
Bishop a5 put the bishop on c8 so all of
a sudden King c8 just aiming to take the
pawn and you cannot just defend the pawn
with the bishop because I'm just going
to slide my king here threatening to
Queen the pawn and then black will have
to go back with his bishop and make a
draw immediately so the pawn pushes
things look even worse for white but
after King b7 before and now he starts
with King d6 a brilliant move
threatening to Queen the only way to
stop it is this attacking the bishop and
now black has two choices either allow
the King to get into the box and stop
his phone or give up his bishop and
allow our queen so draw understood cool
our next example is again the beauty the
beauty of chest composition I think look
at this position it's really really
interesting it's obvious that well black
is up a knight in our position this pawn
is too much for it it's gonna have to
somehow sacrifice his night for the pond
but now the question is from white point
of view should we bring the King here
after which block we'll have to take the
knight with the pawn with the knight or
alternatively should we push the pawn
and then of course the knight will be
obligated to play check and sacrifice
itself here and you might say well what
is the difference why is it even
different there is a difference there is
a huge difference and I will explain
well actually the solution of the game
will be the best way to explain all so
we'll save time
the differences where they exactly and
white and why of course right it looks
like what is the difference if the king
is for all means of purposes all the
businesses here right what is it going
to matter if the king is here in here
right now it looks so elusive right like
if I gave you ten minutes believe me you
will look at it and you think I don't
understand what is it different but it's
a beautiful hard composition and let me
show 87 the correct move check King here
you must sacrifice and I take back and
now I am good and ready to play the move
c5 and queen my beep on so you must go
away as much as possible and now white
plays c5 soon we will see still for now
we don't understand what is the
difference if the King is here or here
you don't see a difference but there is
a huge difference look at it
so takes B 6 C 4 B 7 C 3 I make a queen
c2 now when I can tell you that the
Queen against a pawn on the either the
bishop file or the rook file when they
get to the seventh rank especially when
the king is far away is for the most
part a draw in other words if right now
the black King would have been here this
is a draw you cannot win
why what the not only that but you can
somehow force the wind of my pawn but
then my King is going to go to the
corner let's use our imagination imagine
when the key is in the corner and the
White Queen takes this point what is it
going to be stalemate so that's that's
the difference I'll never have to block
my pawn I can just afford to give it to
you because whenever you'll take here
and my keys in the corner it'll be a
stalemate so in this position it's
winning still because White has a
brilliant resource look at that Queen
h-2a fantastic move he is attacking the
pawn on c2 and now black has two choices
to kill the Queen the pawn or he could
try to support the pawn with the King if
he support the pawn with the
King then my queen just comes to f4 not
letting you Queen anymore
next no I'm gonna play Queen c1 and then
I'm gonna bring my king once the Queen
support blocks the pawn and will never
move this King can be somewhere in Iowa
and it's gonna still come back in time
because it's easy but the big question
is wait a minute why can you why not
just Queen the pawn
well because Queen eight six Chuck
skewering the king and the Queen and now
we understand why the King has to be on
87 and not on 86 if the king was on 86
right now let me go back one move if the
Queen what King was on 86 right now
there'll be no win you will not be able
to squirt the skewer the king in the
Queen really beautiful right very hard I
know this is really I show it sometimes
to my students who are 2,200 and they
have to take a long time before they
understand have to really go through
mega calculations to understand that
some people of course see it immediately
like you've assured the Grandmaster
probably he will understand why do you
need this dagger why does the Queen have
to be on 86 if you stop the king that is
the Queen that has to be on 86 and that
is the answer understood guys and lady
yep okay another brilliant ending that
I'm going to show you from the world of
composition is composed by two players
two composers Durga neither an effect
effect is a good friend of mine I've
shown examples of his before this is a
brilliant example of again in
minimalistic terms this is black to move
and white still makes a draw white is
down a rock but somehow a release King
look how far his King is from his pawns
and yet because this double pawns there
are two pawns he manages to make a draw
well right now white is threatening to
make a new Queen and black can't very
well do this because the pawn will take
it and therefore he needs to find a
solution of how to stop the pawns he
needs to give a check and now the White
King starts stepping closer to the pawns
and he comes further and now the King
starts marching you will already see
that if the rook tries to take the pawns
you can take just one of them King here
rook takes King here now
the black king who is far away from the
arena and I'm just gonna attack the rook
leader from here here pushed upon attack
it further and the route will have to
eventually sacrifice itself at the pawn
right for example let's say King here
King here let's say the rook
I don't know goes somewhere I'm just
gonna threaten to Queen and you can come
here and I'm gonna threaten the Queen
and that is immediately a draw if you
check me I go down if you check me I go
up and otherwise I just make a new queen
so that I think is pretty understandable
therefore what black is trying to bring
his king closer and so is white and they
keep running and running and now it
looks really gloomy again for for whitey
looks like he's about to lose his pawns
but King f7 getting ready to Queen of
course black plays rook to d7 check
again when you look at the position you
think white is just losing the King made
it all the way to eight six the rook is
attacking the King with a check in both
phones are dead but they're not that dad
look at this again paradoxical move King
to g8 amazing just fantastic rook takes
g7 check the other alternative would
have been to take this pawn then I just
put the King on h8 threatening to Queen
and when you take the pawn still mate so
after this rook takes pawn with check
and the King goes to the corner and
again it's amazing it's black on the
move and he cannot avoid stalemate if
King takes pawn it's dumb it if the King
goes away from the rook you're gonna
lose the rock and on any rook move I'm
just gonna go g7 one more time
threatening to Queen the pawn and when
you take it it's done it a brilliant
composition again with so little forces
white manages and against the whole rook
white manages to force a Georgia like an
example of the clumsiness of rook
sometimes understood guys and go yep
okay next position actually I'm going to
jump a little bit ahead to this position
and some of you might say by now some of
you might say you know if this is really
brilliant but is it really practical is
it just the art of chess the beauty of
chess or does this really happen in
games well I don't have too far I don't
have to go far to show you how this can
how composition can apply in games let's
start with this position a beautiful
composition by by hooker who says white
to move and win and at first you look at
the position you just say that's
impossible
yeah sure the black King cannot stop the
pawn but you have a bishop on the
diagonal all I need to do is just push
this pawn here clear the diagonal for
the bishop the bishop will not let the
pond advance and then my king is ten
times closer than the white King to just
go and hunt that form looks like a draw
right no the answer is no now of course
if you push eight seven then I will play
a four now it's really not winning so
white is to be a little more smart and
patient than that and watch what he does
step one he realizes if he got rid of
this Bishop from this diagonal then his
phone is going to cruise to the queen
square understood
so Bishop a seven okay over some chess
base is like not reacting let's see why
okay
it's behaving again and now we
understand I'm threatening to play
Bishop takes pawn
I mean Bishop takes Bishop and then just
Queen my pawn or just push the pawn so
let's say if the King her ass is my pawn
I'm just gonna and I'm quitting it the
moment you try to stop it you lose your
Bishop and I'm winning easily as white
so that's out of the question
but what to do after Bishop a7 what can
you do you have to leave your Bishop on
this diagonal somehow and you see the
bishop c3 is there is pretty much the
same as in the game let's pretend you go
to the corner now I attack your Bishop
same point as before now I'm ready to
just push my opponent Queen so if the
King chess is my pawn I'm just gonna run
and Queen the moment you play efore I'm
just gonna take your Bishop and
eliminate
so you've got a play here King here
Bishop a one the only move on the
diagonal and now this brilliant move by
white watch this amazing move here
because if you keep chasing the bishop
the bishop is going to run away from you
if you play 87 he's gonna play efore and
open the saving diagonal for the bishop
so what does why do bishop d4 fantastic
what is the point if pawn takes then the
King goes to d3 closing the gate now the
bishop is begging to get out of jail but
he can't
and therefore my pawn is just gonna
Queen and alternatively if you take with
the bishop then I go King d3 attacking
the bishop so again it's not easy for
black to play a move like this because
he is just gonna lose his bishop and now
if you play a bishop on the diagonal to
save it
kingi for closing again the door and the
bishop and the pawn is unstoppable I'm
just gonna March the pawn without
stopping
beautiful right a beautiful composition
and again it looks like something oh my
god that can never happen in a game well
it happened in my game an element like
this happened in my game let me show you
how this is the next example I'm playing
against a player in a real game well I
was I can tell you that I was winning
and losing in this game it was a funny
funny game in this position my opponent
is up a bishop but the last move was
Bishop from d1 to a4 was a terrible
blunder all the opponent had to do with
the bishop on d1 it just go King b5 and
I'm I have to give up this pawn and
black would just win easily but instead
one careless move and now watch the idea
I played h5
all of a sudden my pawn is unstoppable
so two choices one is to play take and
one is to try to play check if my
opponent would have played check like
this then guess what I'm not taking the
pawn because then this Bishop is coming
to the long diagonal right he's gonna
stop my pawn no I'm gonna go key c3 just
like we saw in the previous example I'm
not letting
Bishop get to the diagonal so annoying
so my opponent understood that and he
played pawn takes on age five and now I
played g6 and now e5 if my opponent
would have played Bishop to b3 with the
idea of playing a five check and opening
the diagonal for the bishop you might
already guess that all on you would have
done is close the gate just like we saw
in the previous example so theory and
practice you see the composition can
happen in a real game so what happened
in our game after g6 my opponent played
a five check hoping that maybe I will
take the pawn and then can fight on but
I just went King back no bishop you're
not allowed to go on this diagonal how
poor this Bishop is he cannot enter this
diagonal so my opponent desperately took
the pawn I played g7 of course I made a
queen and won the game without any
effort the Queen just took all the pawn
so as you can see this can happen in a
real game okay now our next examples I
want to show you a beautiful position
that I showed one of my students here in
a private lesson again it's a
composition that teaches you how to with
even very few pieces there can be a
world of thinking Maya put my student
had a really hard time with this but of
course I didn't give given much time to
solve it either so we look at a position
and it's queen in two pawns versus queen
and pawn the natural instinct is to
think of the next move how do when you
already think of a plan where should I
put my queen or what should I do
but before you do that you'll be much
better off to think about okay in words
what do you need to do right now you
realize that the blocking is a bit boxed
in he's a bit stuck is not like roaming
free in the middle of the board where he
has freedom he has very limited mobility
he cannot go here he cannot go here you
cannot go here you cannot go here he
only has one do you move out of all the
moves that he has secondly if the black
Queen gets free is gonna drive this King
nuts it's gonna give Chex million checks
and in an open board how is the poor
white King gonna hide right it's not
going to be able to hide so now also we
notice that our queen is vacationing
somewhere far away
and much further than the arena the
arena is here and we need to bring it
into the game how can we do it
notice that we can get to this position
now if I try to play this move they're
gonna be computer will not let me it's
illegal right
look I'm playing Queen b1 to e5 and the
computer whistles and sends the Queen
back but I can do it in a legal way
watch step 1 Queen b5 check only one
move for black he has to block with his
queen now I don't want to give a check
on this square because if I checked here
the King is gonna roam free and now next
move is either gonna go here or here and
try to take my pawns that is not a way
to win with white that's terrible
that I can only lose that kind of way so
the proper move is Queen e2 check again
living black with only one move to make
here's the block and then Queen e5 check
so if you noticed it's like I played
Queen from b1 to e5 without losing any
time and my king was never in danger of
course black must play the move Queen g5
so we have reached the first part of the
game the Queen got closer but now you
might say okay but how to win the first
instinct is to play the move f4 because
you think hey not on them am i defending
my queen but I'm also attacking the
Queen but the problem is that after
takes takes King g5 oopsie the pawn is
being caught and then there is a rook
pawn and that is not winning
that is an easy draw after let's say
here I go here and then I just take this
maybe you can somehow bro take my pawn
but I'm gonna be in time to take this
pawn then run to the corner this is not
a win for white so what to do instead if
you can't play f4 again you have to
think yourself you have to think in a
logical way don't just look for a move
because you know how many moves the
Queen has in this position just imagine
on this diagonal on this diagonal on the
file on the rank a million moves so by
brute force it's gonna take you a lot of
energy you have to ask yourself in words
how do I make a move that gives my
opponent a hard time first of all I got
a prevent
checks I can't go too far from the Queen
with a queen or else is gonna check me
here or here or here or here and then we
know that one's the black the white king
get checked forever it's gonna be very
hard to win so watch what why does he
plays a beautiful move that stops all
the checks and gives gives him a chance
to get even closer to the black king
what really does Queen e6 brilliant now
black doesn't have this cheque and he
doesn't have this check he doesn't have
this cheque and he also does not have
discharge he also doesn't have pawn here
because I just take it to a check then
when I trade Queens this is an easy win
I have two two extra pawns I'm just
gonna go with my king here and by the
time you take one I'm gonna run with the
other easy win so you can't sacrifice
the pawn so you have to move your queen
but where you can't move your queen back
anywhere because that's gonna be
checkmate
your King is boxed in so you have to be
in touch with the checkmate if you try
to remain on the fall here then guess
what this is made so you have to play on
the G file but where - here you will
lose it obviously and here you will lose
it here you will lose it here it's mate
if you go here my pawns can take you and
if you go all the way to g1 then at the
very minimum I'm gonna play a check
check and bye-bye Queen so black has
basically one move in this position to
prolong the game that is Queen GTO now
of course if you play a check the King
goes out check the King can defend the
Queen so how to win now that comes that
now comes the hard part but it's really
beautiful I think you love it
Queen f5 the Queen gets as close as
possible to the King Queen g5 again the
only move it's brilliant to think how
the Queen went to be one all the way to
f5 where black did nothing now I don't
want to give a check here why because
the King is going to come out without
any consequences watch what I'm going to
do first I apply this check only move is
to block
now I'm going to play Queen f7 check and
the poor King has to go here white plays
f4 check ok this stock for a second
hopefully it'll one moment it'll show it
the pawn goes to f4 we check how many
legal moves are black has only one the
King has no legal moves and the King the
Queen has to take and now that the Queen
took away the last escape sir from the
King made forced win for white very
difficult but brilliant really a
brilliant way to dominate with the Queen
first we got the Queen closer then we
made sure that the King was still boxed
in and at the right time we let it out
because it had very few moves and we
checkmated do we understand that who all
right let me see where I am
oh this is another beautiful position
that I'm going to show you and probably
it's going to be our last position for
the day and again we know that a rock
against Bishop for the most part is a
draw why because black needs to run to
the corner opposite to the color of the
bishop imagine if this King was here on
a 8 and then the bishop would be on one
of the squares next to it and there is
no way to win you can any check is going
to be just blocked with the bishop and
you can never keep in because gonna be
stalemate so very very nice however if
the King is closer to the other Square
the the other corner the same color of
the bishop then it's winning
now the pawn here is not very relevant
because you can't Queen the pawn but how
to win white plays g7 he just gives away
his pawn and what is the point the point
is if the bishop takes King g6 notice
the mating pattern the King is opposite
one another and the rook is ready to
deliver checkmate and now it's a big
problem if the bishop just let say go
somewhere here now we took away the
square but we can play here
attacking the bishop threatening mate
the bishop can go here check the bishop
can block but notice that here white
still has a move if this would have been
King here and Bishop here then black
would be safe but now why just plays a
move just a waiting move the King has to
let go of the bishop and checkmate no
defense what to do them how can the Frog
can you defend after this move King
eight seven I'm brilliant move now
you're saying okay maybe now I can take
at some point I can take the pawn but
notice that white just keeps the black
king boxed and he plays rook f7 very
very smart move a brilliant move why the
idea is that sooner or later that pawn
is going to go there's going to be king
and rook versus King and Bishop and with
the rook being here the King is not
going to be able to run to the square
opposite to the color of the bishop
watch how it's done
now he plays rook f7 he plays Bishop
Samuel it's the same thing if you would
have taken the pawn had he taken the
pawn oops sorry of course I'm not gonna
give the bishop the rook for the bishop
I just played a waiting room with my
king you're gonna play a move like this
and then my King comes here we have a
very similar position to the game you'll
see so ruk f7 Bishop d4 and now how to
win with white the King can can do
anything I mean at the right time if you
go away with the king then the bishop
will take the pawn without any danger
and the King will just run away so what
do you do you give away the pond the
only way to win the only practical way
to win of course you must take the Queen
and now King g6 now we understand the
idea of putting the rook on f7 if the
rook would have been anywhere else
the King would start his journey to the
correct corner of the board now he has a
problem so he's gotta play a move with
the bishop of course this doesn't look
very appetizing its mate so now what to
do with the bishop let's say we play
Bishop to g1 the bishop is hiding as far
as possible
and now the win is by keeping just keep
chasing the bishop until you combine an
attack on the bishop with a threat so
for starters we go here
Bishop h2 now rook h1 is also winning
but let's say rook F 2 here and here now
the bishop can long no longer come here
or here he has to rome to the free board
now if you play Bishop h4 then check and
the bishop is gone bye-bye
winning so black is gonna try to play
the move Bishop to d6 rook d2 we keep
attacking the bishop now if the bishop
goes anywhere rook to d8 is gonna win so
he's gonna try to prevent it
and we are going to play rope to see -
beautiful because but the bishop now
took away the scape script for the king
in any other square the king will just
run here but now if you do that I'm just
gonna play check and you can see that
even a de move with the bishop would not
save the game if you would have played
let's say Bishop to e5 then I'm sure
everybody can see rookie - attacking the
bishop and the square e 8 behind it we
have already seen a Bishop d6 all we got
to do is check play a little waiting
move and when the King moves we take the
bishop the only way to win is to give up
the extra material ok guys I hope that
you picked up a lot from this lecture I
hope you enjoyed it thank you much for
very much for attending